when there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to
fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it
so this light is going to be completely
solid like it is right now
and gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
see that's not so scary is it
just you your sister and me
you're doing okay
[Music]
it's not real
it's okay
it's all just in your head
[Music]
oh
Katie there's something in my room
you believe me
don't you
there's no such thing as monsters you
need to grow up
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
you're both having these manifestations
what is this supposed to be
playing that comes for your kids when
you're not paying attention
[Applause]
dad you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle it
[Music]